hello everyone this game was played in
2016 it was the Chess Olympiad in Baku
Azerbaijan and displayed between
Madhubala and Ruslan ponomaryov and it's
a quite an interesting game at first it
seems like a really con game a peaceful
game and then it just explodes and here
is a very interesting statement by
Grandmaster Antone Cora Bob he gave it
in an interview well regarding this game
and but Raja Baba in general
mr. Coralville says all the games played
by mr. Joe Bala are fantastic he plays
very unpredictably and very focused upon
his opponents King you play everything
logically for example in Jabalia versus
ponomaryov this game will analyze just
centralize develop and somehow you find
yourself in a situation where you cannot
defend your king very surprisingly and
well he described it perfectly and it's
a pretty much pretty much the same
description you would use to to maybe
describe Michael Tao and such we're here
at his games as well so let's see this
game Joe Baba has the white pieces and
he plays d4 we have Knight to f6 Knight
to c3 d5 Bishop to f4 now c5 e 3c
capture sandy for a capture sandy 4 and
a 6 preventing a knight to be 5 to
threaten c7 and also preparing to expand
on the queenside AB Bishop to d3 and
Knight to c6 Knight to G 2 e 2 and e 6
we have Queen to d2 leaving the options
available for castling both Queen side
and King side but probably it will be
Kings side b5 expanding on the Queen
side and preparing to develop the bishop
with Bishop to b7 Gabala castles we have
Bishop to e7 and a3 and not allowing any
be for ideas or night to be for ideas
but also weakening the c-4 square which
will black later try to utilize with 92
a5 and night c4
Bishop to d7 not going for Bishop to b7
we have h3
we have castles rook F 2 e1
Knight to a5 now black is ready to put
the plate Knights the c4 and we have
rook a to d1 and first mr. ponomaryov
plays Queen to b6 and thus Queen to b6
is I believe what what motivated them
Java to create such a such a common
again full of combinations but you'll
see what I mean here he plays Knight to
g3 the pawn cannot be captured if you
capture upon with the Queen Bishop
character some h7 and black loses the
Queen now since Bishop captures on h7
comes with a check so after night the g3
we have rook after c8 and now black is
definitely ready to play Knight to c4
and here we have a most interesting move
by Joe Bala that was definitely inspired
by this Queen to b6 move he plays Knight
to f5 and this is a very interesting
move because it leaves black with a
couple of options do you capture this
Knight and allow rook captures on e7 if
you do what what do you do then do maybe
maybe move the bishop with Bishop to d8
or Bishop to f8 there are there are a
lot of ideas here so let's see a couple
of them playing Bishop to d8 would
actually be a terrible blunder if Bishop
to DA then a white has Knight captures
on g7 and if you capture you get a
Bishop to h6 with check out King to h8
and Queen to g5 and now threatening a
checkmate with Queen to g7 checkmate so
this has to be defended night to e8 and
now Queen to h5 now positioning your
Queen to attack h7 as the bishop on d3
is already doing so so King to g8 after
the dark square Bishop moves you would
have King f8 to escape but now comes
nice captures on d5 would a temple on
the Queen and after he captures on d5
you have Queen to g4 check and black is
lost it doesn't matter what you do if
you capture the Queen with Bishop
captures on g4 you get a rook to e8 with
checkmate if you don't if you play
something like for example King to h8
you get Knight rook
actors and I ate with Czech Bishop has
to capture and now Queen to g7 checkmate
and lastly if you simply block with
Queen to g6 as well this Bishop is also
attacking whites Queen you simply
capture the Queen and white still can
the black still can't capture the Queen
on g4 because of rook captures any
checkmate
so this after Knight to e5 Bishop to d8
wouldn't be that great of an idea but
let's see a bishop to f8 bishop tell
fate also isn't the best defensive
option because yo baba had this resource
of knife to h6 check and if you play
King to h8 you lose this f7 pawn with
check so after G captures on h6 you get
Bishop captures on h6 and if Bishop
captures Queen captures now the knight
on f6 is attacked and after Queen to d8
rook to e5 and there is no defense
against rook to g5 so very very
interesting idea this Knight to f5 ID
move so ponomaryov captured it he
captures an f5 was played and rook
captures on e7 and okay Bishop to e6 I
mean this rook is now trapped good luck
getting it away from there after a move
like King to f8 but Jove Allah planned
for this as well he plays a Bishop to h6
and it's a it's interesting
well black still has options here but
let's see what happens if King to f8 is
played if King to f8 now then Bishop
captures and g7 would check King
captures any 7 and now Bishop captures
on f6 if you capture the Bishop Knight
captures on d5 with check with the Royal
fork forking the king and the Queen and
if you capture the night you get Queen
to h6 check out King has to move and you
lose this Queen on b6
so after Bishop to h6
King to efface it definitely isn't
something you would want to play and
ponomaryov captured the bishop with G
captures and h6
are more resilient maybe my idea would
be nice to h5 but this also doesn't seem
very well
after queen 2g5 you get you have you to
have this Knight to c6 move or a temple
on the rook but now simply rook captures
on e6 and after captures rook Queen
captures on h5 g captures on h6 and
Queen captures on h6 and a much better
position for white you can't capture a
pawn for example like this or you get
Knight capture some d5 again with a
temple on the Queen and threatening
Knight to f6
so after this Bishop h6 move it was
captured G captures on h6 and here we
have Queen captures on h6 and what do
you play here rook captures on c3 was
tried by ponomaryov if you play
something like if you try and save this
knight on f6 for example with Knight to
e4 this simply doesn't work because
Bishop captures on e4 and after for
example he captures D captures on e4
Knight to d5 and black is lost at the
threat is Knight to f6 check followed
with a queen to h7 checkmate you have to
capture this night and after Bishop
captures again you lose the Queen on b6
so after this Queen to h6 rook captures
and c3 was played and now not capturing
the rook or the night but a brilliant
idea a queen to g5 check forcing the
King to go to f8 so King f8 was played
and now Queen captures on f6 now
guarding the rook also I'm the queen and
b6 and also in some variations
threatening Queen to h8 and grabbing
this rook on a 8 and what's the real
plan here well if black tries to save
this rook for example with Roxy to c8
you get Bishop captures on f5 and there
is nothing white can do here if you play
rook to e8 you get Bishop captures on e6
and this is lost if you play something
like Queen captures Queen captures and
wrote captures Queen to HH check and you
lose the rook on a 8 this is winning for
white and after this
Bishop captures on e6 if you play rook
captures ninety-seven this is the whole
point of getting the King to go to f8
and now you have Queen to h8 checkmate
so brilliant idea this Queen to g5
pushing the king away to f8 so after
this Queen to f6 rook captures and III
was played but now see capture son d3
and Rose don't wanna Mario resigned the
game because the threats are still there
this doesn't really achieve anything
for example if Queen to c6 regarding
that rook against any Bishop captures an
e6 and queen to h8 ideas with grabbing
the rook on a8 rook sorry rook to e1 and
black is helpless here again rook to e8
rook captures and again you lose the
Queen if you play rook captures any 7 a
queen to h8 is checkmate and if you try
to maybe hang on with Queen captures and
e6 you get rook captures rook captures
and out Queen to d8 check and after rock
blocks or the King moves away you lose
the knight on a file with Queen captures
an a5 and that is it after this seek
after sandy three move Roslin Palmero
resigned the game and well this this
masterpiece was created so that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it as usual
you can check to all my previous videos
here I would like to thank Donna pirates
Alan Connick Sean Wilcox and Andrew
Sinclair for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
thank y'all for watching and I will see
you soon